Professor Robert Shiller:
Before I begin,
I just wanted to say that I was
very--I found last period's
lecture with David Swensen very
interesting.
Also, I liked being serenaded
by New Blue, which is a first
experience for me.
Swensen--He gave,
I thought, a very interesting
talk.
I've heard him talk before but
it's always interesting.
He really emphasized
diversification.
But, I don't know what you were
thinking, we got a 28% portfolio
return last year.
There's something else going on
besides diversification;
diversification means we get
the average return.
And I was glad that you asked
questions at the end.
Some of your questions seemed
to draw out other things that he
doesn't plan to talk about,
like what he really did to make
money.
One thing was that he said that
they shorted the Internet stocks
in the late 1990s.
That's a brilliant market
timing device that--I think
enlightened people thought that
those prices were getting
high--and also made some play on
credit spreads and now on real
estate,
he said.
How does he do it?
Again, it's my theory that
there's no--you can't entirely
be taught, but partly though I
think that he does it,
as do other good portfolio
managers, by just keeping a very
broad base of knowledge and
listening to people and
collecting information and
watching the big trends and
thinking about them.
One of, I think,
Swensen's best talents is he's
a good listener and he
incorporates basic facts and
acts on them.
You might have--it would be
incorrect, I think,
in listening to what he said
and conclude that he just says
diversify because he's obviously
done something very different
from that.
By the way, I have another
speaker who told me that he
would like to talk to our class
and I hope we can work it out.
His name is Carl Icahn,
who is one of the biggest Wall
Street--powerful and enlightened
people on Wall Street--who can
also maybe tell us something
about how he makes money or how
he makes it a better world.
The problem is that he has
a--these people have very tight
schedules and he's involved in
various takeovers and things
right now.
He said he could do it if we
could arrange to meet after 3:00
p.m., so I'm going to--on a
Monday or a Wednesday,
perhaps at 3:00 p.m.
or later.
He said--his assistant said it
might even be 7:00 p.m.,
so that's the way he works.
I don't think he gets up at
9:00 a.m., apparently.
So, I take that that's all
right with you--that you can
come to a special section of
this class.
We would have to see if we can
arrange that.
Again, I don't guarantee that
it will happen because the
reality is, someone who is
involved in as many things as he
is--it's going to be something.
We do have Stephen Schwarzman
coming February 22^(nd) and we
have Andrew Redleaf coming March
5^(th),
so we have a really strong set
of outside speakers this year.
Again, the mid-term exam is
Monday;
sorry that I misstated that
last week.
You've already seen last year's
mid-term and it's going to look
a lot like that.
We're talking today about
interest rates and bonds.
Interest rates are an old,
old thing.
They go back to ancient times,
but I'm going to talk about
some of our modern institutions
and I'm going to talk first
about discount bonds.
This is a little bit more of a
technical lecture,
but I find it just as
interesting myself.
We're talking about discount
bonds, and then coupon-carrying
bonds, and then talk about the
term structure of interest rates
and why we have interest rates.
I think that's my Blackberry
beeping.
I'm trying not to live in too
electronic a world.
That's the way it is these days.
It's giving its last gasp.
Then finally,
talk about inflation index
bonds.
The first thing is a discount
bond.
It's the most simple--or often
called a bill--a discount bond
does not pay interest;
it's sold at a discount.
You have the principle,
which is the amount owed,
which is, let's say it's $100,
that will be paid to you at
some date in the future,
specified in the contract.
And nothing,
you would just get $100.
Effectively,
you get interest from this
because it's sold at a discount,
so the price that you pay is
equal to one hundred minus the
discount.
You wouldn't buy this bond at
par because--at par,
meaning at $100--because then
you wouldn't get any interest on
it.
So you buy it at a discount and
the return you get is of course
a hundred minus--the return you
get is the discount.
The U.S.
Government is a big issuer of
discount bonds and they're
called Treasury bills.
I have them up on the screen
here.
This is from a U.S.
Government website called
treasurydirect.gov and you can
get on and access it at any
time.
It is showing--since the U.S.
Government issues these bonds,
it's showing its data on these
bonds.
The bonds are auctioned off on
regular dates and you cannot
participate in the auction;
I assume you can't.
You'd have to be an authorized
participant, but if you become
an institution you can get
authorized to trade in the
auction.
These are the dates;
the latest auction was February
14^(th).
I guess that was yesterday,
right?
The term means it was a
sixty-day Treasury bill;
that means it pays not $100,
it would start at $10,000.
Treasury bills--maybe you have
to realize there's a distinction
between savings bonds and
Treasury bills.
Treasury bills are for serious
investors and so they don't come
in small denominations.
The U.S.
Government also issues small
denomination debt to individuals
to help them called savings
bonds, but we aren't talking
about those.
At the February 14^(th)
auction, Treasury bills
were--sixty-day treasury bills
were sold and the auction price
is given.
Well, here's the price of the
bill.
The issue date was today,
February 15^(th),
and they mature in what should
be exactly sixty days--on April
15^(th).
If you want to buy one you
would pay this price.
This number,
CUSIP number,
is a number that identifies any
security.
It's like you have a social
security number or other ID
number, which positively--there
might be another person with the
same name as you,
God forbid, but you at least
have your own number,
which is guaranteed to be
unique to you.
So every security has an
identical CUSIP,
which identifies it.
I want to start by explaining
the numbers here.
How did they get--how do these
numbers interrelate?
Well, the discount rate is sort
of the--you notice there are two
different interest rates here
and you might be confused by
them.
The discount rate that is shown
is the number that you plug into
a formula to get the price.
What really matters to you as
an investor is how much you have
to pay today to get $100 in
sixty days.
So, how do we get the price
from the discount rate?
Well, there's a formula that's
been used by bond traders for
hundreds of years and it's a
traditional expression,
which goes from the discount
rate to the price.
In this case,
price is $99.58 and what does
that equal?
It equals 2.51--that's the
discount rate that you see up
there--well, (2.510 x 60)/360.
As you know,
the maturity is 60-days and,
as you know,
there are about 360 days in a
year.
By tradition,
they divide by 360,
not 365, and so you understand
that dealers of Treasury bills
tend to "discounts."
It's like a language,
a language of finance.
So what everybody knows is that
the discount is converted into a
price according to this formula.
You might ask,
well is this an approximate
formula?
No, it's an exact formula.
Then you say,
well why didn't they divide by
365, because I know there are
365 days in a year?
The answer is--this goes way
back--it's an old tradition and
they used to have to do this by
hand.
They had to divide by hand and
so they didn't like the number
365, so they thought,
let's just round it to 360.
As long as everybody knows
that's what we're doing,
what difference does it make,
right?
That's what you're supposed to
know.
If your dealer quotes you a
discount rate of 2.51%,
you know how to convert that
into the price and that's all
that matters--all that really
matters is the price you have to
pay.
They also have something up
here called the investment rate.
Yes?
Student: I'm sorry,
I don't understand since the
left hand side of your equation
does not equal the right hand
side,
isn't that discount, not price?
Professor Robert
Shiller: I'm sorry,
glad you--that's the difference
between 1 and 99.58.
Yes, thank you--between 100 and
99.58.
Are you okay now?
I'm sorry I made a--now the
thing is, to convert that
into--what is this
other--there's another interest
rate up here called the
investment rate.
Well, that's supposed to be
your percentage return on an
annualized basis.
Remember, this thing only runs
for sixty days and you could
compute your sixty-day return,
but people like to compare
annual returns--once again,
a tradition we have.
Now, there's nothing special
about annual--that's the time it
take the Earth to go around the
sun,
but it doesn't have any
relevance to finance--but we are
just accustomed to using that.
What we're going to do,
however, is take account of
another problem.
That is, you might think that
this quantity here is my return
but you have to actually divide
it by the price,
which is less than a hundred,
to get a return.
You're not putting in $100 to
this investment;
you're putting in $99.58 for
the investment and you're
getting out the difference
between $100 and $99.58.
So, that is not--your return is
actually higher than 2.51% on an
annualized basis.
What we do--I'll show you how
they got their number.
2.563%, which is the number you
see under investment rate,
is equal to 1/(.9958 –
1), corrected for the number of
days in a year.
How do we do that correction?
When I first tried this,
I thought, fine I'll multiply
by 365/60, but I forgot this is
a leap year.
So, times 366/60.
So, that's how you go from the
discount rate to the investment
rate.
Do you understand why we had to
do this?
The investment rate is telling
you how much money you're really
making on an annualized basis,
so it's very simple.
I put in .9958 for every dollar
I got out, so my appreciation of
my money is 1/.9958.
Subtract that by $1,
which is what I put in,
and that's how much money I
made as a fraction of a dollar.
All I have to do then is
correct that for the number of
days in a year,
so that's what I did.
That's how we go from the
discount rate to the investment
rate.
Now you might ask,
well if we did 360 here,
why don't we just do 360 over
here?
Well, it's one of the mysteries
of Wall Street.
They like to--when they're
computing the investment yield,
they want to be completely
honest and not use any rules of
thumb.
So you have to understand that
it's 360 a year because that's
just a convention and everybody
knows that it's just the way we
quote prices.
Rather than say $99.58,
we just quote the 2.51 and
everybody knows how to convert.
When you ask for the investment
rate, you want to know the
truth--how much am I really
getting--so they don't monkey
around here.
Also, they don't have to
actually--in the old days,
they didn't actually have to
compute the investment rate.
If you were talking to your
broker--if you go really old
days, you'd send a boy running
over to your broker.
They didn't have telephones;
they used to have runners.
The boy would go say,
we're offering to pay a
discount rate of 2.51--that was
the formula--and then anyone
could do these calculations;
they knew what it meant.
This calculation wasn't done
very frequently;
that's just if you had one of
the satisfactions of knowing how
much money you were making.
I think we pretty much
explained--there's another thing
I want to say about Treasury
bills.
I used to have up here a
page--I used to take--instead of
Treasury Direct,
which is a website,
I used to get a clipping from
The Wall Street Journal
that showed much the same
information that you see on this
chart.
But, it showed additional
information that you won't find
on Treasury Direct;
it showed bid and ask for
dealers.
Now, you have to understand
that the Treasury has these
auctions only on these dates.
On February 14^(th),
they only sold sixty-day ones,
nothing else.
On February 11^(th) they sold
only thirteen-week ones and
nothing else.
What if you want to buy a
Treasury bill on some other day?
Well, you can go to Treasury
Direct as an individual and buy
a Treasury bill,
but it may not be the best
place to buy.
What you normally do is you go
to a dealer and a dealer is
someone, a professional,
who participated in the auction
and bought these up to
accumulate an inventory to then
sell off to you,
the customer.
So normally,
you don't deal with Treasury
Direct, you deal with a dealer.
The Wall Street Journal
calls around to the dealer,
which has an inventory of all
these maturities and asks them
for their bid and ask.
And a dealer--what a dealer
does is it maintains an
inventory of,
in this case,
Treasury bills and then it
stands ready to buy and sell.
So, the bid price is the--they
don't do it in terms of price,
they do it in terms of
discount--so the bid discount
rate--there would be two numbers
for each.
One is the bid,
which is what they'll pay you
for a Treasury bill if you want
to sell to them.
The ask is what you have to pay
them through this formula.
The formula is--I could write
it this way: price equals one
hundred minus this.
Normally, when you have a
dealer, the dealer has a--when
we talk in terms of price the
dealer has an ask,
which is higher than the bid.
If you go to an antique
dealer--maybe you're familiar or
maybe you've done this if you've
bought furniture for some
apartment or something.
The dealer will charge a higher
price for you to buy the
furniture than will give to you
to purchase the furniture from
you;
that's how the dealer makes a
difference.
The difference between bid and
ask is the profit for the dealer
and the bid-ask spread is the
profit for the dealer.
You can see these--you can see
the bid and ask in The Wall
Street Journal.
It's interesting to look at it
because you note that the
bid-ask spread,
which is the difference between
the bid and the ask for the
dealer,
is narrower in the more liquid
securities and some of the
securities that are small and
unimportant have a wide bid-ask
spread.
That means that it's harder to
make a market for it,
so the dealer wants to charge
more.
This doesn't show this here.
Unfortunately,
The Wall Street Journal
stopped carrying this and I
thought--it's an interesting
story about what goes on.
The Wall Street Journal
is the most influential
financial publication in this
country but it has been going
through financial difficulties
with the Internet age.
In the last five years,
the stock in Dow Jones Company
has fallen by half.
What's happening?
Well, there are many factors,
but one important factor is,
the rise of the Internet has
competed with--people used to
buy The Wall Street
Journal to get data like
this.
You see how I completely
bypassed The Wall Street
Journal and I went to
Treasury Direct?
There are a million websites
that give away financial data so
The Wall Street Journal
was not doing as well.
Do you know what happened
finally?
I'll give this as an aside;
they reduced the size of the
newspaper in 2005.
It used to be a big,
broad sheet and they made it
smaller in 2005 and they
started--they keep cutting out
data.
There's less and less data in
The Wall Street Journal.
It used to be this big,
thick thing and you would go
there everyday to look up--and
everything was in there.
But now, the Web is competing
with it, so they're scaling down
the size of the paper and trying
to survive.
So, they created Wall Street
Journal Online,
which is WSJ.com,
and they were trying to make
money off of that,
but people weren't willing to
pay for it.
You know how it is on the Web?
You can get so much for free,
why should I pay for WSJ.com?
That wasn't working well,
so last year--about one year
ago--they announced,
wallstreetjournal.com is
absolutely free and we're going
to give away all the data,
basically all the data that
used to be in the newspaper,
free to anyone.
I thought that was great.
Now we can all get The Wall
Street Journal without
paying for it.
There's some problem with that;
it's not economic,
so let's not be too jubilant.
What ended up happening is,
you know the news,
Rupert Murdoch bought The
Wall Street Journal last
fall and he announced that Wall
Street Journal--WSJ.com--will no
longer be free.
So, this is the reality of the
world.
I thought it was interesting to
look at Rupert Murdoch--this is
finance.
This may sound like an aside,
but this is all finance.
Rupert Murdoch,
you may have heard of him,
is a huge newspaper baron who
buys up newspapers all over the
world.
It's interesting,
he's been at it--he's
continuing what his father did.
To become the biggest
publishing monolith in the
world, it takes maybe a hundred
years, so his father in
Australia started buying up
newspapers.
His father was born in 1886 and
now Rupert Murdoch is
continuing.
Rupert Murdoch is in his 70s
and he's still buying
newspapers.
He kind of makes them survive
and NewsCorp doubled its
price--that's his
company--doubled in the last
five years.
You can see,
this is how the unseen rule of
finance--The Wall Street
Journal is a venerable
newspaper and source of
information about finance,
but it's not making money.
The world is changing and
The Wall Street Journal
is flagging.
So NewsCorp,
whose price doubled when The
Wall Street Journal's fell
in half,
eats up and The Wall Street
Journal is gobbled up by the
bigger company.
You can see why stock prices
matter.
The Newscorp's rising stock
price was a sign that Rupert
Murdoch had some idea how to
make money and The Wall
Street Journal was not doing
as well,
so it got gobbled up.
The question is,
what will happen to The Wall
Street Journal now?
Well, they have to make money;
that's the real world.
So Rupert Murdoch tends to
bring papers around.
I'm just going to go a little
bit further on--Rupert Murdoch
bought The Times of
London in 1981--that was
twenty-seven years ago.
The Times of London is
one of the most venerable
newspapers in the world and it
was losing money fast;
it might have disappeared if
Murdoch hadn't taken over.
But, Murdoch turned it around
and it's still around.
They turned it into a tabloid.
It was the most dignified
newspaper in the world and he
kind of decided that,
in order to survive,
they had to get a little bit
more down to earth.
So, they reduced the size,
so it looks like one of
those--like New York Daily
News newspapers now.
It's still a great newspaper.
He added celebrity gossip too,
which The London
Times would never do in the
past.
But you go to do it, right?
That's the thing about the real
world and finance is very much
about the real world.
Murdoch claims he will not
alter the editorial content of
The Wall Street Journal.
The thing that we have seen him
doing is charging more,
but I guess we've got to allow
that.
So we may feel annoyed that we
now have to pay to get our
Wall Street Journal
Online.
In the long run,
we want The Wall Street
Journal and so I guess
that--we just have to accept
that.
If you want to find--by the
way, if you want to read The
Wall Street Journal online
at Yale, you can do it no
problem.
You go to ABI Inform,
which is one of the things that
Yale subscribes to,
on your laptop and it puts you
right into the text of The
Wall Street Journal.
But it doesn't put you,
as far as I can tell,
into Wall Street Journal
Online.
We have other--lots of data
sources--that Yale subscribes to
and there are lots of free data
sources,
but Wall Street Journal
Online is not free.
Anyway, I want to talk--you
understand now about discount
bonds?
It's pretty simple, right?
I just wanted to get the
pricing formula.
The critical thing about a
discount bond is it pays no
interest.
Treasury bills in the United
States are limited to one year
out;
well, that's the name of it.
We call an instrument of the
U.S.
Treasury with a maturity less
than or equal to one year--we
call that a bill--and they used
to be the only discount bonds
issued by the U.S.
Government.
Now, they also have longer
maturity, called Treasury
strips, but let me move to the
other.
So we have--U.S.
Government issues bills and
that's less than or equal to one
year and they pay no interest.
They also have
government-issued notes and
that's from one to ten years and
bonds--this is just
jargon--these are ten or more,
well actually more than ten.
I'll show you from Treasury
Direct--I have notes--this
should be greater than ten.
These are the recent auctions
of the Treasury of notes.
Now, these are different from
bills, as I emphasized,
because they pay interest.
They carry what's called a
coupon.
And then we have the bonds.
You see there aren't as many of
these issued.
We issue a lot of–there
are a lot of auctions of
Treasury bills and there are
comparatively fewer of bonds.
So, let's talk about a bond.
A bond differs from a bill in
that it carries what's called a
coupon, which I will denote by
the letter C,
and it has a principal,
which it pays out at the
end--of one hundred.
Of course, there would be
larger denominations than $100,
but by tradition,
we speak of them as if they
were bonds that you paid $100 to
get.
Now, another Wall Street
tradition is that bonds pay a
coupon;
they pay C/2 every six
months.
The coupon is expressed as an
annual amount;
you get half of it every six
months.
The reason they call them
coupons is that,
in the old days,
you used to actually--when you
bought a bond,
there would be a piece of paper
and the piece of paper would
have attached to it a lot of
little coupons that you would
clip.
If it was a twenty-year bond,
there would be forty coupons,
one for each six-month period,
and each one would have a date
on it.
What you used to do is,
every six months you'd pull out
your bonds and you'd clip the
coupons with a pair of scissors;
you take them to a bank and
they would give you cash for
your coupons.
So, we still call them coupons,
but now we don't do it--we do
things electronically.
You don't have to clip coupons
anymore.
If you want to see bonds as
they used to look,
with their coupons,
there are a number of them at
the International Center for
Finance down the street here
with their coupons still
attached.
So they've got a lot of--Will
Goetzmann and Geert Rouwenhorst
are collectors of old bonds and
they've got lots of bonds with
their coupons still attached.
You know what that means when
they're framed there on the wall
with their coupons still
attached?
It means the company went
bankrupt and never paid;
otherwise, the coupons would
have been clipped.
It's actually--our
International Center for Finance
is sort of a museum for
defaulted bonds.
The ones that are beautiful for
framing are the ones that
failed, so you can see all the
coupons.
Some of them have some of the
coupons clipped and then they
stop and you know that it was
bad news when they stopped
clipping them.
We still call them coupons.
If you have a bond with an
interest rate of 4.375%--that's
not an easy one to divide by
two--but you would get half of
that every six months until
maturity.
We have to ask then,
how do we get the price and the
yield from this?
What we do is we take the
interest rate,
which I'll call r,
and plug it into a formula,
which I didn't actually do the
arithmetic to check--to check
their number.
The price is just the present
value of the coupons at the
interest rate r,
so the price of a bond is the
present discounted value of
coupons and principal,
at rate r.
Now, you have to understand
that when you buy a bond,
if you buy it at issue,
you get the first coupon in six
months, the second coupon in one
year, the third coupon in
eighteen months,
and the last coupon you get at
the maturity date.
So that means--what is the
stream of payments?
You get C/2 in six
months, C/2 again in a
year, C/2 again in
eighteen months,
and that continues until the
last date--the maturity
date--when you get 100 + C/2.
The price is just the present
value of that stream,
discounted at the interest
rate.
The formula can also be written
and expanded out--P =
(c/2) x
[(1/(r/2)--which is the
consol formula,
if this were applied to an
infinite stream-- -
1/(1+(r/2))^(2T) x
1/(r/2)].
Let me make sure I've got this
right-- +100
(1/(1+(r/2))^(2T).
This should be obvious--if I
did that right--this should be
obvious from what you learned
about in present value formulas.
If you had a perpetuity,
which paid C/2 forever,
you already know from the
perpetuity formula that the
value of that would be
C/2 divided by r/2
if r/2 is the discount
rate.
It's not forever because it
terminates after 2T periods of
six-month interval each.
You want to subtract off the
value of a perpetuity that
starts after 2T,
six-month intervals,
so this is the present value of
the perpetuity that starts after
2T, six-month intervals.
Then you want to add the
present value of the principal
and that's the formula.
That's another conventional
formula that goes from interest
rate to price of the security.
Now, I want to talk about the
term structure of interest rates
and that's my next plot here.
That's the term structure as of
now on the chart.
We've identified the prices and
yields of bonds of various
maturities.
How do the prices and yields
look at various points in time?
So, I've got here a term
structure;
well, the term structure is the
plot of yield-to-maturity
against time-to-maturity.
This is January of this year,
before the Fed cut interest
rates, and this is the term
structure.
I've got the Federal Funds
Rate--it's the shortest interest
rate, an overnight rate--it was
at 4% at that time and then
there was a sharp drop.
The three-month Treasury bill
rate is shown there--it was much
lower--it was under 3%.
Then the--so the term structure
was downward-sloping until about
two and a half years and then it
was upward sloping.
The interesting question from
the standpoint of economic
theory is, why did it have that
funny shape?
I want to compare it with other
examples of the term structure
recently.
This is the term structure just
a short while ago--of December
2006--very different.
The Federal Funds Rate was 5.5%
and then the whole term
structure--all the way--almost
all the way.
Well, there's this funny glitch
here between three-month and
one-year, but then it just
continued to decline.
That's a strongly
downward-sloping term structure.
This is another example,
not so long ago--this is
December 2003.
Now, the term structure was
pretty much upward-sloping
everywhere.
At that time,
the Fed had cut the Federal
Funds Rate to 1%,
we had very low short rates.
And the three-month Treasury
bill rate was about the same,
at 1%.
Going further out,
the term structure just kept
rising.
It's one of the questions of
economics--what determines the
term structure?
You have to understand that
it's determined in the market.
The Fed has these auctions but
it auctions them off at what
price the public will pay,
so the Fed doesn't determine
the term structure.
Neither do the dealers
determine the term structure;
the dealers have to buy and
sell at prices that are in the
market.
It has to stay relevant to the
market, so nobody really knows
where these interest rates come
from because no one person sets
them.
If you're a dealer,
you've got to keep your bid-ask
at market;
otherwise, you'll get only one
side or the other,
right?
You'll be selling too cheaply
or you'll be buying too dearly.
You've got to do it so you're
right in the middle,
so that the market is in the
middle.
Nobody really sees the reason
for this;
it's all a question of theory,
so we have to think a little
bit about theory.
The term structure is one of
the most interesting things in
economics because it shows the
price of time at various
maturities.
In 2003, time was almost free
out three months.
It didn't--if you needed more
time to get some business done
you'd have to borrow,
but you'd only have to pay 1% a
year.
That would be like a quarter of
1% to postpone your payment by
another year;
so time was really cheap.
But if you wanted to postpone
it over seven years or so,
time got a lot more expensive.
Why is this and why is the
price of time changing?
One thing to do is to go back
and ask, what really are the
reasons for interest?
I wanted to talk about the
theory of interest as presented
by Professor Irving Fisher at
Yale, who is famous for having
exposited that.
I imagine he did it at this
very blackboard because,
as I said, he had his office in
this building and he didn't die
until 1940s,
so he must have been--this
building was--this room goes
back to the '30s.
He had a diagram,
which illustrated what is the
ultimate cause of interest,
and it helps us to think about
this diagram whenever we try to
understand the term structure.
What his diagram--this is the
famous Irving Fisher
diagram--depicted,
there's only one period;
there's today on this axis and
tomorrow–well,
I shouldn't say tomorrow,
that suggests one day--next
period on this axis.
Let's say it's one year and I'm
going to actually plot on this
axis a person's income this
year.
I should say income today on
this axis and on this,
income next period.
So for each person,
there is a point representing
my income today and my income
next period.
Let's assume that I know what
I'm earning next year;
there is actually uncertainty
about it.
If I draw this down this--this
point is this year's income down
here and this point here is next
year's income;
I'll use Y for income.
This is Y today and this
is Y next period.
A person has a budget
constraint if the person can
borrow and lend at the interest
rate.
The budget constraint is a
straight line through this point
with a slope of (1+r).
I'll try to draw this line.
That should be a straight line.
It doesn't look that straight
because I was running out of
room up here.
You see, that's a straight line.
This point here then is the
present value of your income;
it's (Y _today
+ Y _next
period) / (1 + r).
What's this point up here?
This point up here is the
terminal value of my income,
so the upper point is (Y
_today *(1 + r)
+ Y _next year.
In an ideal world,
where you can borrow and lend
freely, an individual could
choose consumption along any
point on this line.
I could consume all of my
income--if I borrow against my
future income,
I could--there's a problem here
of starvation.
If I consume it all this year,
I will be starving.
I don't see how I can earn
income next year but,
in principle,
that's what Irving Fisher said.
Well, I could just not consume
anything this year and I could
wait until next year and consume
the terminal value.
I would take my income this
year, invest it at the interest
rate, and it would turn into
Y today times (1 + R) and
then I get income next year;
so I could consume all that.
I can consume at any point
along that line as well.
I could consume at today's
income, or I could consume here,
or I consume down here.
If I consume less than my
income today,
I'm saving and my consumption
would be lower this year.
Am I doing that right?
No, if I'm saving this year my
consumption would be less than
my income, so my consumption
might be here and I would then
have more next year.
Each individual reaches a
decision--each individual has an
income point and decides how
much to consume based on the
budget constraint.
Now, the interest rate in
Irving Fisher's world has to
equate supply and demand in the
market for debt.
Each person who wants to borrow
has to be met by somebody else
who wants to lend,
so the interest rate that we
have in society is the
compromise.
It's the interest rate that
clears the market for loans and
that interest rate determines
the market interest rate.
Nobody can see the interest
rate--why the interest rate's at
the level it is in the
market--because nobody can see
all these individuals;
but that's why the interest
rate gets determined and is in
equilibrium.
Why the interest rate
clears--it's a mysterious
phenomenon, because it's a
market phenomenon and each
person only sees his or her own
contribution to the market and
not the whole market.
Irving Fisher also drew on the
curve a production possibility
frontier for society,
which he made downward-curved.
This is production possibility
frontier and that is a
curve--you've seen these before
in economics--that says how the
production of our society can
produce different combinations
of income this year and next
year.
If there were no credit
markets, everyone would have to
be on the production possibility
frontier;
there would be no other choice.
But if we have credit markets,
then people can individually
choose to be off the production
possibility frontier and at a
higher level of consumption than
otherwise would.
You might have some people up
here who are saving and other
people down here who are
dissaving and the production
would be operating at the
middle.
So, that is Irving Fisher's
diagram in a nutshell,
but I think it's--so what does
it say about the term structure?
It says that at different
horizons everything on this
diagram is different.
The production possibility
frontier at different horizons
is in different places.
The budget constraint is going
to have a different slope to it
and preferences will be
different over this horizon
between consumption then and
consumption now.
So you--it doesn't--this theory
doesn't say a whole lot about
what the term structure will
look like but it suggests that
it's determined by the interplay
of lots of economic factors.
I want to talk about a couple
of other basic concepts in
economics of interest rates.
One of them is the forward rate
and the other one is inflation
indexed interest rates.
Forward rates--I wrote a survey
article years ago about the term
structure of interest rates and
I wanted to find out who was the
originator of the term "forward
rate."
I asked my graduate student
research assistant to research
the whole literature and find
out where did the word forward
rate come from.
My graduate student came back
and said, it seems to have been
Sir John Hicks in London in his
1931--1939 book,
A Value in Capital.
This is another aside.
but I think it's motivational,
and so I said,
are you sure that J.R.
Hicks invented the term
"forward rate"?
He said, how can I be sure?
I mean, I've looked through
everything;
I can't find any earlier
reference.
And he said,
I think it's J.R.
Hicks.
Then, I was talking it over
with another graduate student
and he said, well if you want to
find out why don't you ask J.R.
Hicks?
And I said, wait a minute,
is that guy still alive?
He said, I think he is.
I found out he was living in
London--Lord Hicks;
I guess he got knighted for his
contribution.
I wrote him a letter and I
said, basically,
did you invent forward rates?
Then, I didn't get any response
for like three months and then
to my surprise I got a
hand-written letter,
in kind of a trembling
handwriting;
I still have it.
I should--I can put it up on
the screen actually.
He said, my apologies--he was
very polite and diplomatic.
He said, my apologies for not
answering your letter but my
health is poor and--but it was a
long letter.
He said, I'm trying to remember
where I got the idea and,
he said, I think it probably
came from some of our coffee
hours at The London School of
Economics in the 1920s.
He said, we were discussing
that, and then he said,
I thought it was in a book that
my wife and I translated from
the Swedish in the 1930s but,
he said, I've looked and it's
not there.
So he said, I guess maybe it is
my idea--I was the first person
to write it up.
Then he died shortly
thereafter, so I got to him just
in time.
I thought I would describe
forward rates in terms of the
coffee hour at The London School
of Economics in the '20s.
This is J.R.
Hicks talking--so the year is
1925--and we're talking about
investing in discount bonds and
we're going to put £100.
Now suppose--the idea that
Hicks invented is that they're,
implicit in the term structure,
there are future interest rates
already quoted.
I showed you the term structure.
I showed you a one-year
Treasury bill rate for right
now--that's not right now,
but you can see I have a
one-year and a two-year Treasury
bill rate.
The idea of a forward rate is
that, implicit in that term
structure is also a quote for
the one-year rate,
one year hence,
because if you look at the
two-year rate,
can't you infer back what
interest rates are going to be
in one year?
Because the two-year rate
is--you've got the one-year rate
and the two rate,
so between the two,
what's left?
The difference between those
two somehow reflects what
interest rates will be between
one and two.
What Hicks said--this is the
coffee hour conversation at The
London School of Economics--he
said,
it's right now 1925 but if you
want to invest or borrow in 1926
I can do it for you.
I can lock in the interest rate
right now.
So let's say,
okay I expect--suppose I expect
to get £100 in 1926.
Here we are,
sitting in 1925,
and I want to,
today in 1925,
lock in the investment return
that I will get when I invest
that hundred pounds.
So, what we want to do--this is
what Hicks discovered--I can do
the following transaction to
lock in,
in 1925, the interest rate
between 1926 and 1927.
Here we are sitting in 1925;
I'm going to buy in '25 this
amount of two-period bonds--two
year-bonds--(1 +
r_2)²/(1 +
r_1).
These will mature and be worth
£100 in '26 and I'm going
to short how much?
I'm going to short one
one-period bond.
This is the number of bonds I
have to buy and so let's analyze
this.
That's all I have to do and I
have locked in the interest
rate.
r_1 is the
yield on the one-period bond and
r_2 is the
yield on the two-period bond.
The price of the two-period
bond is 1/(1 +
r_2)²
and the price of the one-period
bond is 1/(1 +
r_1).
If I buy this amount of
two-period bonds,
how much does it cost me?
It costs me 1/(1 +
r_1).
If I short the one-period bond
it cancels out,
so I've made no net purchase in
1925.
I bought a number of two-period
bonds such that the value of my
purchase exactly equals the
proceeds that I get from
shorting the one period bond,
so I've made a zero wealth
transaction.
It hasn't affected my
portfolio--my cash position--at
all.
What happens then in--that's in
1925, so there's no cash flow at
all.
In '26, what happens?
Well, in '26,
the--I've shorted the
one-period bond and so I have to
pay out one dollar,
but that's exactly what I
wanted to do.
Remember, I said I'm doing this
because I expect to have a
hundred pounds--I said one
dollar--I'm going to have to pay
out a hundred pounds because
this one-period bond,
worth one hundred pounds
principal, is coming due so I
have to pay it out.
That's what I wanted to do
because I said I'd have a
hundred pounds to invest.
Nothing happens to the
two-period bond because it just
continues to mature.
So 1926, I pay one hundred
pounds.
What happens in 1927?
Now what happens is,
I now get the maturity of this
bond.
What I get--I have purchased
this number of bonds,
so I'm going to get a hundred
pounds times that amount there,
the number of bonds--(1 +
r_2)²/(1 +
r_1).
You can see that by doing this
transaction I have locked in a
return between 1926 and 1927.
I did it in 1925,
but I've got it set up so that
I will pay a hundred pounds in
1926 and I'll get this in 1927.
He calls the forward rate equal
to (1 +
r_2)²/(1 +
r_1).
This is Hicks's discovery.
You might say,
this should have been obvious
to someone, but it had never
been written up well before.
What Hicks said is that in
these term structures,
you don't just have today's
interest rates--this is a
map–actually,
I've just showed the
one-period, he had one-period
forward rate--but you could do
it over any combination and you
can get forward rates of any
maturity at any future date.
That's Hicks's insight and it
comes back then to Hicks's book,
Value and Capital,
in 1939.
He said that we shouldn't think
that the--the simplest story of
the term structure of interest
rates,
which he expounded there,
is that forward rates equal
expected future interest rates.
That means, in the
simplest--it's called the
expectations theory of the term
structure.
It says that the forward rate,
which you can compute from
today's newspaper or from
today's website--you can compute
the forward rates for all future
dates.
What he says is those forward
rates are what people think
interest rates will be in the
future and that's called the
expectations theory of the term
structure.
Forward rates equal expected
future spot rates.
If you look at the December
2003, what's going on?
It's very clear and that is the
Fed had just cut interest rates
to 1%--it was unusual--it was
much talked about.
People didn't expect that to
hold and so people thought,
well it's going to still be
down at 1% maybe in three
months.
So, you can see the term
structure doesn't go up between
overnight and three months.
But they are expecting that the
Fed is eventually--and they were
right of course in this
case--the Fed is eventually
going to raise rates.
The upward-sloping term
structure means that the forward
rates are at higher levels.
So, that's the expectations
theory.
Hicks also talked about another
theory in his 1939 book,
which is--there's the
expectations theory,
but there's also a liquidity
premium theory.
This is the theory that there's
risk in longer-term bonds,
so there's a tendency for
upward-sloping term structure
even if expectations are flat.
So, according to the
expectations theory augmented
with liquidity preference--This
strongly upward-sloping term
structure in 2003 would reflect
two things.
One is that people expected
interest rates to go up and,
secondly, that interest
rates–longer-term
bonds--are riskier,
so there's also another effect
pushing interest rates up.
The last thing I want to talk
about is just--I'm running out
of time here and I want to
mention this before your
mid-term exam,
which is next Monday and covers
everything through this
lecture--something about
inflation and interest rates.
Inflation--we'll call that
π--the inflation rate is
π.
So right now,
it's something like 2% or it's
a little bit higher last year,
but maybe it'll be 2% going
forward.
The real interest rate,
computed from nominal rates,
is equal to one plus the
nominal rate divided by one plus
the inflation rate,
so it corrects for inflation.
If you have an interest
rate--this is approximately
equal to--one plus the real
interest rate is equal to one
plus the nominal interest rate,
divided by one plus the rate of
inflation.
So we would say the real
interest rate equals the nominal
rate--approximately equals--the
nominal rate minus the inflation
rate.
If we have--right now,
if we go back to our current
term structure–well,
this isn't complete.
If you look at the current term
structure, it's interesting.
Look how--this is as of earlier
this year;
the Federal Funds Rate was at
around 4% and it has this huge
drop in the term structure and
then it starts the
upward-sloping.
Why is that?
That's because on the date that
I got this term structure
everybody knew the Fed was
cutting rates and they got it
exactly right.
The Fed was cutting rates to 3%;
they knew it was coming but not
today.
Right now, we have a Federal
Funds Rate of about 3% and an
inflation rate of around 3%,
so right now the real interest
rate is close to 0.
Finally, I just want to say
that we have also a kind of bond
called an indexed bond,
which is a bond whose coupons
are indexed to inflation.
With an indexed bond you don't
have to do this calculation to
get the real rate.
The yield-to-maturity on an
indexed bond is already in real
terms because the coupons are
indexed to inflation.
In my final slide is a picture
of the first indexed bond;
this is issued by the State of
Massachusetts--I actually own
this bond.
I bought it for $1,000 on a
website because I was interested
in indexed bonds.
I could have brought it to
class and showed it to you,
but this was issued during the
Revolutionary War to help
finance the war.
Now, what happened was the U.S.
Government--or the
Massachusetts Government--had
created high inflation during
the war and nobody wanted to
lend money to it so they create
here a price index.
It says the price index
contained this amount of beef,
this amount of sheep wool,
this amount of sole leather,
and this amount of corn;
that was the first consumer
price index ever used for
financial contracts.
We now have something else
called the Consumer Price Index.
This bond was paid off,
the U.S.–Massa
chusetts--didn't fail to pay on
it in 1784.
But anyway, indexed bonds are
about 15% of the U.S.
national--I'm sorry,
about 8% of the U.S.
national debt--about 15% of the
U.K.
national debt--and they are
very important but still a
minority of all of our fixed
incomes.
That concludes this lecture and
I won't be here on Monday,
but we'll have our lecture in
this classroom on Monday.